it really is it's it comes back to
experimentation and I think it's really
hard thing to do and it's a scary thing
to do because you've got in some cases
these there's the the session the Jeff
Zucker talked about trading into analog
dollars for digital pennies and I think
he recently updated to say digital dimes
and so it's very scary to sort of make
that transition to say well I'm putting
this huge enterprise at risk for an
uncertain future but I think that that
so many of those forces that are taking
place are going to take place you know
whether or not you want them to or not I
mean the train has left the station in a
number of different instances and so to
sort of sit back and say well I want to
roll back the clock five or ten years
ago I get why that that's that would be
you know people want to do that but i
think it's just it's it's hard if not
impossible to do and I think that's not
where your your your users or your
readers are going to go and so it's
really important to try and find
different ways to try and push the
envelope and test those things which I
again I acknowledge a hundred percent
that's that's that's tricky and that's
scared to do but I think it's if you
don't you're sort of you've got bigger
challenges down the road
well I think the path you know 20 years
ago is sort of the same you start off
that it may be a small regional paper
and to work your way up and then you get
to the times of the journal and I think
in you know we're talking a little bit
about how users and other readers and
their experience with with information
is now much more active before is very
sort of passive they'd sort of sit back
and the information we presented to them
now it's much more of a dialogue and I
think there's there's there's a bit of
an analogy as well with with the
journalist today and that it's not just
sort of this passive thing where I write
my content and I put it out there
somebody puts that content a thurs and
is responsible for the distribution of
my content and I sort of sit back and I
continue to write that content to write
those stories I think it's it's much
more of an active role to own your you
know your brand and your experience in
your information how that gets out there
and understanding the technology at your
disposal so you can get that out there
understanding how you can tell stories
in better ways I think a lot of the you
know we couple times we've gone over to
to CUNY which with their new journalism
school and I think that's an interesting
idea it's a new school so I think that
the way that they're thinking about it
and really I think one of the phrases
they use an entrepreneurial journalism
and i think that's that's that's that's
true whether you've been in the business
for a number different years or whether
you're just starting off it's this this
you're thinking about the content and
the distribution of it and then and the
monetization of it I mean all these
things kind of matter so much more that
simply just putting a piece of
information out there is probably not
going to be enough and so to really try
and immerse yourselves in all those
different ways whether it's you know I
think there's always been the church and
state and I think there's that
separation is obviously therefore for a
lot of good reasons about not making
sure that your the information that
you're writing isn't influenced by an
advertiser but I think sometimes it can
be used as a way to just sort of put on
the blinders and say why I'm never going
to think about the business side of it
you obviously need to keep your content
separate from that but that doesn't mean
you can't think about the long-term
viability of what you're trying to do
you